david assouline fait une erreur
colossale d'ailleurs ça justifie c'est
de penser qu'on va refaire alors qu'on
est arrivé là où on en est arrivé avec
les divisions que vous avez connu je
vais pas rappeler comment public sénat
pouvait avoir ici de gens qui
contestaient à l'intérieur de la
majorité la politique était conduite
parce qu'il y avait des divergences
horizon de fonds si la question consiste
à dire je refais une alliance parce
qu'il faut se rassembler sans essayer à
un moment quand même de redonner de la
clarté
une solidité idéologique et politique à
un parti social qu'est ce qui va se
passer
et moi je sais ce qui va se passer a
même jamais j'aurai connu la même chose
que ce qu'on a connu
parce que de dire il ya plus de droite
et de gauche du parti surtout de la part
de david assouline qui était plutôt sur
la gauche du parti
et puis de dire comme ça on fait un
grand rassemblement est à peine ce
rassemblement est fait et bien on
recommence
les batailles c'est ce qu'il ne faut
plus c'est bien ça le sujet et d'aborder
la question du congrès en dix ans et les
anciennes méthodes
mais non c'est justement ce que dit
david assouline qui est l'ancienne
méthode cette idée que il suffit de se
rassembler et puis après on verra
oui je sais ce qu'ils ont à l d'eau à la
synthèse hollandaise h alors là je
tourne le ski et le paradoxe est pas moi
qui ai pas mal c'est ici c'est un parano
c'est que ce qu'ont contesté la synthèse
hollandaises sont les premiers
maintenant à la revendiquer j'ai même vu
certains dire qu'il fallait une synthèse
nouvelle écoute et ils ont contesté et
la synthèse de hollande je le rappelle
elle s'est faite sur un sujet qu'elle
était majeure d'ailleurs c'est pas au
congrès de dijon n'y a pas eu de
synthèse il y avait déjà la question des
retraites vous avez oublié d'en parler
la retraite à 60 ans les durées de
cotisation françois hollande à ce moment
là n'a pas fait de synthèse avec henri
emmanuelli à l'époque du beau monde et
avec arnaud montebourg et vincent
peillon du nouveau parti social je
rappelle juste ça la synthèse a été fait
sur la question du traité
constitutionnel européen
après les déchirures du oui idée non
c'est là qu'elle a été fait et bien
cette synthèse qui a été fait là après
un débat de congrès d'ailleurs au mans a
été fait et on a bien vu que la question
de leur en est revenu de manière
régulière
parce que certains n'ont toujours pas
voulu accepter cette idée que dans le
projet européen
il ya des politiques différentes qui
peuvent être conduites il faut qu'on
défende social-démocrate une politique
européenne mais que le fait a priori de
dire c'est l'europe qui est un problème
ça c'est pas la position qui doit être
celle du parti socialiste jean-françois
ligne quelle ligne politique incarné
vous qu'est ce qui vous distingue de vos
concurrents dans la course à la tête du
ps quelle ligne politique
les sols sur la ligne sur la ligne je
les 10 par rapport à olivet fort qu'est
ce que je pourrais dire d'abord je n'en
sais pas grand chose aujourd'hui mais il
a été avec moi d'ailleurs comme
directeur adjoint au moment où on est et
où j'étais directeur de cabinet de
françois hollande donc je connais
olivier faure et sur ce sujet j'attends
d'ailleurs ce que va être le
rassemblement qui je le dis quand va de
si j'ai bien compris de martine aubry en
passant peut-être par valérie rabault et
jusqu'à philippe doucet qui était un
proche de manuel valls
je me dis simplement que si on repart
comme ça c'est exactement ce que je vous
dis on risque de se retrouver après le
congrès avec des sujets qui n'auront pas
été traitées et qu'ils se ont traité
qu'après dans l'ain moment où dans des
moments où au contraire on aura besoin
d'être rassemblée
profitons de ce congrès pour essayer de
clarifier les choses et c'est les
militants qui doivent choisir c'est eux
c'est leur liberté cette fois ci on les
a trop oublié